how good could a fantasy possibly be
unless it's got dragons the dragon yeah
you need the Dragons and in my home
institution the American Museum of
Natural History we had an exhibit a few
years ago that was all about mythical
monsters and whether they were the
imaginations of people who discovered
fossils of extinct dinosaurs Wow yeah so
a magic you know you know Triceratops
imagine that
emerging from the eroding side of a
cliff right clearly no animal you've
seen its extinct yeah but the concept of
extinction is a modern idea yeah few
hundred years ago so here's this thing a
candidate it must be some some monster
yeah that we fear in the night and so so
no no I you know I think you love
dragons because they're great if they're
your friend but if they're not they're a
super predator that's another theory
actually about where we have this idea
of dragons from that's even more ancient
than the idea of people discovering
fossils this idea that it might date
back to when we were very frightened of
apex predators and anthropologist called
David E Jones he puts forward this
theory he studied vervet monkeys in
Africa and he noticed that they are
particularly anxious about three
predators lions Eagles and snakes and so
they have a particular cry that they
make when they see any of these three
creatures really and if you sort of
merge those three creatures together you
sort of get something that resembles a
dragon so he again is sort of used this
to get you like this is this the cry
[Music]
translator
so when you think about if you have
something as ferocious as a lion that
has the the body type of a serpent such
as the snake but it can fly as a flying
predator such as an eagle yeah I'll give
him that so every time yes he has this
idea that we would have this sort of
passed down through millions of
generations we were to revolve this fear
that's so great that we've created this
primal amalgamation yes where does the
puff I mean we're all scared of I mean
we would be scared of fire but that's a
headed that after I say we want to make
it even more for us right
[Music]
[Music]